قال مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي جيك
سولفن ان تقديم المساعده الامنيه
لاوكرانيا يحظى بدعم قوي من الحزبين في
مجلسي النواب والشيوخ
الامريكيين نعتقد ان هناك اغلبيه قويه من
الحزبين في كل من مجلسي النواب والشيوخ
لتقديم هذه المساعده لاوكرانيا وهذا ما
نتطلع لرؤيته اتيحت لي فرصه لقاء القياده
الديمقراطيه والجمهور واعضاء لجان الامن
القومي الرئيسيه في الكونجرس خلال جلستين
منفصلتين كان اللقاء بناء وموضوعيا وكانت
لدى المشرعين اسئله ممتازه والكثير من
الاقتراحات البناءه حول الطريقه الاجدى
للاستمرار في المساعده لاوكرانيا وحشد
العالم
لمساعدتها تنضم الينا من البيت الابيض
مراسله الجزيره وجد وقف وجد اذا نتابع معك
هذه الزياره حزمه مساعدات جديده لاوكرانيا
ماذا تشمل ونوع الجدل المحيط بهذه
المساعدات من قبل او بين الحزبين الجمهوري
والديمقراطي فدا حزمه مساعدات تشمل دبابات
ومدر ومدرعات وذخيره وكل ما يحتاجه الا
الاوكرانيين يعينهم في فصل الشتاء الذي
توقع الرئيس بايدن ان
يستخدمه الرئيس الروسي بوتين كسلاح ضد ال
الاوكرانيين وبالتالي توقيت هذه الحزمه
بالنسبه للاداره الامريكيه لاوكرانيا على
حد سواء جاء مهما ايضا الرئيس بايدن اكد
بانه مع بدء الاسبوع المقبل سوف تتسلم
اوكرانيا دبابات ابرامز هذه الدبابات التي
طال انتظار اوكرانيا من اجل تسلمها اي نظ
نظرا لقدراتها
ال المتفوقه على ارض المعركه كانت بحاجه
لعده اشهر طويله خضع حلال خلالها الجنود
الاوكرانيين للتدريب على كيفيه استخدامها
وايضا على كيفيه صيانتها الرئيس بايدن اكد
ايضا خلال لقائه بالرئيس زيلنسكي على ان
الولايات المتحده مع جهود احلال سلام في
اوكرانيا وهي تدعم هذه الجهود ولكنه قال
ان الرئيس بوتين هو وحده من يقف عقبه امام
السلام وبان الولايات المتحده لا تريد
لهذه الحرب ان ان تنتهي ولكنه في ايضا في
الوقت ذاته اكد بان الاداره الامريكيه
مستمره في تقديم هذه المساعدات مهما
استغرقت الحرب من وقت هذه المساعدات
حقيقه بالنسبه لل الظروف الان هنا في
واشنطن الكونجرس هناك اصوات معارضه في
مجلس النواب وايضا مجلس شيوخ من قبل
جمهوريين بالنسبه لجيك سوليفان هم قله
وبان الاغلبيه في الكونجرس يرغبون ب
مواصله تدفق هذه المساعدات الامنيه
لاوكرانيا لماذا كل هذا الجدل لماذا زار
الرئيس زيلنسكي اليوم الكونغرس واجتمع
باعضاء من الكونغرس من الحزبين الجمهوري
والديمقراطي وذلك لان الاداره الامريكيه
طلبت 24 مليار دولار لتغطي تكلفه
المساعدات الامنيه لاوكرانيا خلال العام
المقبل هذه الحزمه ما زالت قيد النقاش
جمهوريون يع رضون هذه الحز الحزمه ومواصله
تقديم مساعدات لاوكرانيا لكن بالنسبه
للاداره الامريكيه هي تعتقد بان هذه
الحزمه سوف تحظى بموافقه الكونغرس المهم
بحسب جيك ساليفان هو التوقيت فال توقيت
المساعدات يرغب البيت الابيض بان يتم
اقرارها بحلول الاول من ديسمبر فدا شكرا
لك وجد وقفي مراسله الجزيره كنت معنا من
البيت الابيض